welcome to Horace Horace the channel
where we discussed the latest tech news
and dove into newest tech products today
we're taking a look at how AMD is
actually holding back the rise in 720
800 X to compete with the Intel i7 9700
K but before we delve into that make
sure to hit that subscribe button if you
guys like to stay updated with the
latest tech news related to gaming and
pcs well if you guys didn't already
notice horizon 7 Series this year only
has 2 CPUs as opposed to 3 CPUs that
there were last year so this year
Amy's actually lacking the 2800 X now
this may just be because AMD wants to
keep it simple and they don't want to
make it a bit confusing like last year
when people didn't really know what the
difference between a chips were because
they were pretty much identical in the
first place however it may also be
because they're keeping it in store but
whenever Intel comes out with their
octa-core processor later this year and
so they can compete with it and maybe
even beat it as for the octa-core
processor from Intel is going to be
called the 8800 K or 9700 K and it is
going to have 8 core 16 threads but it
is only gonna be on the clock for the
platform so it's pretty much just a
coffee like refresh but with 2 extra
ports also they're going to have to get
a new chipset which is the Z 390 chipset
we don't really have much details about
this new chip other than that it's going
to be on the Z 390 platform but
considering what Intel's out right now I
think it's pretty much required for them
to come up with the octa-core processor
considering how much value Ami's putting
out and as a result I think we can
safely assume that this will indeed have
8 cores and 16 threads however it may
not work in Intel's favor like they
expect with the 8700 K the max official
boost clock speed is four point three
gigahertz and if we take a look at the
AMD rise in 720 700 X it's turbo speed
is also four point three three Hertz
however has two more cores and four more
threads and is cheaper not to mention
it's motherboard and CPU cooler so as
you guys can see the 2700 X is already
in a really good position against
in tow the max boost to speed frequency
that we've seen across the board brento
is four point five you Hertz with their
Intel i7 7700 K but that only had half
the cores and half the threads so Intel
may not be able to deliver that much
performance with the 9700 K and if you
take a look at the i7 78 20 X which is
an Intel octa-core processor on the
enthusiast line then you'll see that
it's maxed turbo frequency is four point
three gigahertz and because of all this
I think the max turbo frequency that we
expect for this new octa-core processor
from Intel is four point three or maybe
four point five Hertz but that's pretty
much it and as a result the rise in
seven twenty seven hundred X is pretty
much identical with the 9700 K s coming
later in this fall despite that as price
is much cheaper first let's take a look
at the minimum amount that you guys
would need if you want to get on to the
Intel 9700 K so first of all the i7 9700
K will probably cost over four hundred
dollars because the ATM under K costs
three hundred and eighty dollars MSRP
and so what it really makes sense to go
lower than that and so I would say it
has to cost at least four hundred
dollars it'll actually probably even
cost like 450 or something but will give
until the benefit of the doubt and just
assume that's gonna be cost to four
hundred dollars and then for the
motherboard the Z 390 motherboard will
probably cost at least $150 so that's
one two right there
and if you want to have a decent CPU
cooler like what AMD rates stellt offers
then that'll be about thirty dollars for
something like the hyper 212 Evo so the
grand total for Intel is five hundred
and eighty dollars now let's take a look
at AMD so further 27 red X and the CPU
cooler it only costs three hundred and
thirty dollars and on top of that you
can use it with budget boards like be
450 which will probably only cost $100
not to mention you can use it on even
the be 350 you may even be able to pick
up a mother for much cheaper than $100
but if you do want decent motherboards
and I do recommend that you go with the
be 450 for about 100
or $120 so the grand total for AMD is
about four hundred and thirty dollars
now I know that if you were to overclock
Intel and AMD past their max turbo
frequency Intel almost likely perform
better
however the 2700 X is not far behind
it'll provide you with about over 90% of
the performance of the 9700 K but it
only costs 75 percent of their cost so
as you guys can see AMD just wrecking it
with value once again now so far we only
just discussed the 2700 X so what if AMD
came out with the 2800 X so first of all
the 2100 X would at least be point two
here it's faster than the 2700 X or
there's really no point in even having a
reiteration so the 2800 X should at
least support four point five degree
Hertz and we may see anything up to like
four point eight gigahertz so that would
be about the range for the max turbo
frequency for the 2800 X so on paper the
2800 X will be identical it's not better
than the 9700 K so people who aren't
interested in overclocking and things of
that nature can just go ahead and get
the 2100 X and not even worry about it
even when overclocked I think that the
risin 7 2,700 X will perform at least
95% of what 9700 K will offer honestly I
feel like that will perform 97% or above
or maybe even beat it but let's not get
our hopes up too much asked for price I
expect that the 2800 X will cost
anywhere from 350 to 400 dollars but I'm
leaning more towards the $350 side
because of how lenient AMD has been in
the past so as it is evident Intel CPUs
have already been pointless for the vast
majority of buyers in the last year and
with this new 2700 X and possibly a 2800
X there really is no point to go for
Intel any more so should you wait for
the 9700 K well usually I would tell you
guys that if you really want the best
performance and are willing to spend the
money then it's definitely worth waiting
for but now
amy has pretty much caught up with adult
and
performance increase is really
negotiable and so it really doesn't
matter and I really don't think any of
you guys should wait for it and you guys
should just go ahead and get the rise in
27x right now or 2800 X if it ever comes
out overall Intel is already at a very
devastating point right now and if AMD
comes out with the 28 X then that's just
a nail in the coffin
not to mention that AMD is already
playing to come out with her 7 animator
processed CPUs next year while Intel has
been working on their 10 nanometer of
CPUs for the past 4 years and they once
again delayed it but that's a story for
another video so what do you guys think
is Intel actually done for or do you
think that can easily come back if they
just start offering their C please for
more reasonable prices make sure to
comment down below what you guys think
because I do read all my comments I'm
curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also
make sure to hit that like button if you
guys like this video and if you would
like to see more videos just like this
every single day can make sure to
subscribe but until next time bye
[Music]